e
all right so welcome to a hopefully
brief I say that um executive session of
the special committee on housing the
first order business I want to take up
um is we're receiving Senate messages um
I just received a senate message about
HB 1168 which if the committee were
members is that study committee to deal
with um the housing crisis on people
with disabilities um all the Senate did
was amend it to put out the effective
date make an interm report honor before
November 1st 2024 and then have a final
report by November 1st 2025 to give them
more opportunity to look into this
should they want to I am planning on
concurring is there any objection to
that I just want to bring it across the
committee do not concur
concur okay um so the next order
business I'll entertain a motion on SB
408 which is relative to um the same
study committee um studying the impact
of the housing crisis with people with
disabilities I move itl okay U moved by
representative re itl someone thinks
differently is there second second by
discussion it's the duplicate of what we
passed and that the Senate just slightly
changed and passed and that we're going
to concur
on okay so seeing no other comments the
rule Vice chair
barudi representative makoni
yes rep representative Walsh yes clerk
votes yes representative yella yes
representative D Lorenzo yes
representative Reed yes representative
Murray yes representative Damon yes
chairman Alexander yes unanimous all
right Z we're going to put on consent if
there's no
objection awesome so the um last order
business we have is s SP 527 um relative
to student housing um the committee
heard testimony on a non- gerine
Amendment a couple weeks ago after the
public hearing on that um representative
Reed I will recognize representative
Reed for a motion thank you Mr chair I
would like to move uh amendment number
and I'll second that thank you um and I
would speak to that go ahead um so we
had a hearing on a non- gerain amendment
to address the issue as the chair just
said to address the issue of
occupancy um and that Amendment
completely replaced the committee the
study committee on uh housing for
students and it was my understanding
that while that is definitely a great
step in the right direction it's not a
silver bullet there are other issues
impacting student housing that still
would remain to be studied and I thought
that it would actually be more
strategically helpful to combine them
rather than replace if for no other
reason then the Senate is more like to
accept it if we're not taking out what
they put in so for the amendment before
you simply adds the language of the non-
gerain amendment that we had the hearing
on onto the bill which is a study
committee rather than replacing
it okay any other comments on this
amendment okay is the show of hands okay
for the amendment oh representative
Walsh yeah um I guess I'll be consistent
I won't be supporting this amendment um
not so much for another study committee
that we probably don't need either but
but but on what what the remnants of
1281 and what this does and I don't know
I served a lot long time on a planning
board and it's my understanding and
understanding that the majority of the
time ordinances are created when towns
have an issue um in the words of my late
Mentor chair of hooks of planning board
for many years he said look I don't like
rules either he said and and he said but
if if everybody respected each other and
each other's rights and property rights
we wouldn't need any of them but that's
not reality I look at this these are
college towns for the most part that are
doing this I wasn't there I don't know
what kind of issues they have and and
from what I heard at the hearing uh by
preventing them from doing this we may
get their issues back and I did not hear
and actually I heard the contrary that
this probably isn't going to do anything
for improving College housing anywhere
not for pricing not for availability
because these are fixed numbers of
students in most most cases I just
ordinance are there for a reason it's
that not every planning board and Zoning
Board is nefarious they had issues they
found a way to fix it and keep in mind
this has been around since what was it
1986 so for those reasons I just I just
can't get into their issues without
knowing why it's started in the first
place thank you representative Reed
thank you Mr chair I do appreciate the
concept that ordinances are there for a
reason I think that we strive um at all
levels of government to reach that
balance and and the different levels of
government are a type of checks and
balance so this is an example of where
the state is stepping in and saying that
those ordinance are overly restrictive
um which we've seen time and time again
but yes uh ordinances pertaining to
Behavior where it as um as the concept
is not respecting each other things like
loud Behavior or garbage those
ordinances are untouched and I think the
point of the amendment as we had the
hearing on is that we can have
ordinances about Behavior without
discriminating against a type of person
um and there's really no reason to say
that students specifically or renters
specifically should have um restrictions
that other people don't have if it's a
if it's a behavior problem those
ordinances are allowed so I will support
the amendment obviously
represent
call thank you
um I think that kind of I have to agree
with um the
representative uh that this is really
about discrimination that this is about
inappropriate discrimination of of
people and not an actual harm being
uh perpetrated on the neighborhood or um
safety it is
essentially uh that that those those
ordinances were placed I think on the
books
for uh I saw an email that came out
um that was forwarded regarding this
bill that municipalities don't want to
enforce these noise noise
ordinances or um they're not cracking
down on that and I think that a single
person uh living in in their own house
uh by themselves can be loud I know
because I've had the cops called on me
for being loud because I fell asleep
while watching TV and it was so loud
that the neighbors can hear it
I felt I was sleeping fine and so I
think that they were mad about that
situation and there was no one there
except for me and so um I think that if
there's a problem with noise if there's
a problem trash then they need to
address that um you know through the
health and safety type of uh situation
but if you know if my girlfriend is
there and we're not married or we are
married that doesn't make us any more or
less less safe um I think that is uh you
know just uh they're trying to capture
some thing uh by regulating something
else and I think that um just because it
may be hard to you know enforce nor
ordinances at a certain time of day or
something like that that doesn't make uh
it appropriate for them to discriminate
in a different way to try and alleviate
those issues so I will be supporting the
amendment thank you
represent
M thank you um I I must have missed a
meeting or one of these uh work sessions
we had so I apologize I'm looking at the
amended
analysis uh Bill includes student
housing and Municipal Workforce housing
regulations so there's a definition for
Workforce housing and this is adding
this category in am I wrong about
that I think
addressing the bill as underlying bill I
believe not I'm just going to your
amended analysis on the back but the
amended analysis still in incorporates
it's not an analysis of the amendment
the amended analysis analyzes the entire
Bill if should it be adopted with the
amendment so it's still speaking to the
underlying bill there's nothing in the
amendment that talks about that but my
point is the bill does address that you
you're adding an amendment to to that
that's the amendment that's before me
and the um is based on um family
non-family relationships m s among the
occupants property restricts the number
of occupants of a single bedroom to less
than
two that means one person in only only
every bedroom in this building can only
have one person is that what what I'm
reading here simple I'm a simple guy is
that what I'm reading the cor so I'm as
a co-sponsor of the original bill that
was heard in Municipal killed and then
came forward as a non-gain Amendment
which now this is the same Amendment but
including the original Bill instead of
replacing I will speak to the I spoke in
that in that hearing um so the issue is
we have a number of towns um Durham is
the like the number one town that spoke
um that say that they will not allow uh
unrel more than three unrelated people
in a a house regardless of the number of
bedrooms and what this is saying is that
at least a town has to allow couples
pered one couple per bedroom that's not
what this says it says less than two
what number shall not restrict to less
than two
right space restricts the number of
occupants of a single bedroom to less to
less than two which means one line
16 right line 11 shall not adopt line 11
shall not adopt any of the following
which is anything that restricts the
number of documents to a single of a
single bedroom to less than two so it
cannot say that you can only have one
16 yeah line 11 so that's one and two
those numbers one and two are part of
that list the thing that's defining the
list is in the the paragraph above
it in its exercise of the powers granted
under this subdivision the legislative
body of a city Town Village District or
county in which there are located in
unincorporated towns or unorganized
places shall not adopt nor shall the
governing body thereof enforce any
ordinance related to the occupancy of
any existing new or single family duplex
or multif family dwelling unit that one
is based on familiar or non-familiar
status two restricts the number of
occupants per bedroom to less than two
so so it shall not do one or two and it
and in in in in the amendment it says
that b says that they they can enforce
the state building and fire code so um
they can restrict it in cases of safety
safety or or health
yeah does that clarify your question I I
understand your point I will not be
supporting
okay any other comments okay is the show
of hands okay for the amendment I don't
I don't know how they're going to enfor
I I still don't get this line 16 what
this means less than two to me says
one go ahead represent Damon so if you
read line
11 and then read that as the beginning
of the sentence that continues with line
16 what it's saying is that it shall not
adopt a
restriction of the number of occupants
of a single bedroom to less than two so
in other words it is permitting at least
two residents per
bedroom to be fair you could have they
could have rewarded that to say shall
not restrict it to only one they just
worded it differently to less than two
less than two means
one doesn't mean one and a half or yeah
or a half represent Murray uh uh thank
you Mr chair um so I guess one other
question that I did have when you're
talking about not less than two if there
were some other need like a health need
or a reason for them to be somebody to
have a single room that would be
hearing represent V
colum um I I think you I I think um that
question is essentially like if a person
chose to have their their occupancy of
being being one bedroom but this is
talking about the zoning saying the
entire town essentially you cannot have
you know if you have a two-bedroom house
you cannot have more than three people
in your house or because this is this is
um just um occupants of a single bedroom
right and so if they make a blanket
statement of you have a three-bedroom
house and you can only have four people
in the house then that would essentially
be in contrast in in contradictory to
this law because that is less than two
per bedroom and so that would not be
enforcable however you could choose to
obviously inhabit a a three-bedroom
house with only one person if you wanted
to they just wouldn't be able to mandate
it represent re I thank you again and
just very briefly I think ideally we
would say something like if you're going
to have uh restrictions that the
restrictions can only refer to like
State Building Code or fire code it has
to be if it's for you can't discriminate
based on renter or student or whatever
but they it still allows that it just
says that you can't discriminate and
restrict it to under two so it still
allows that so if the occupancy of a
house is
10 they could still restrict it as long
as it wasn't less than two and wasn't
based on familial status so I think we
still give the municipalities lots of
room to kind of get in there and and see
what's best for them but I think this is
a bare minimum that we that should be
allowed represent
WS last for me as I said I'm not going
to be supporting it but I I just wanted
to comment on this being discriminatory
and and I
disagree uh this was challenged in court
if I'm not mistaken and I think if it
was uh found discriminatory in any way I
don't think it would have survived uh
but it did so thank you
very briefly please very briefly I
appreciate that the definition in law of
discrimination has to do with certain
protected classes and whether or not
you're enrolled in school is not one of
those classes how and so therefore it
makes sense that the court case came the
way it did but we heard repeated
testimony from people from Durham
specifically saying This was meant in
all of their ways whether it was rental
term or what have you all other ways
they were specifically trying to Target
students they said that so you can say
it's not discrimination legally but I
think all of us know that it's targeting
person represent makoni thank you lastly
and I don't think you need my vote on
this and you're not getting it the um we
have a hard enough time sitting here
trying to focus and and be able with a
straight face say what is Workforce
housing I mean it's the hardest thing
I'm going through in my county and
everything else and here we open up
another another student housing in
Municipal Workforce housing and I think
that makes it difficult to create
Workforce housing so and and
representative to address that I believe
the um the reason why it says in
Municipal Workforce housing regulations
because that's the RSA they put it in
but the underlying Bill 527 is merely a
study committee to look into this and
then the non- derain amendment is just
tacked onto the study committee so I
understand where you're coming from but
it's not the reason why they did is
because it's in the r in that RSA so um
I mean the study committee will come up
with what they come up with um but I
think that the Crux of this is the non-
derain amendment which I think is a
valuable step in the right direction
thank you okay okay are we ready or yeah
I'm just GNA say uh seeing it is just a
study committee I think I'll let it you
know vote for it to go forward and let
the study committee work out any other
details
just point of word I mean point of
clarification if I may Mr chair it is
not just a study committee with a nerain
Amendment attached to it correct there
is another underlying Bill the
underlying bill is the study committee
yeah and then this adds that portion on
yes this is unrelated adds the unrelated
renters or ordinance but it's not
related it's it's vaguely related in
that the study committee is on student
housing how to deal with housing with
for students and we had a bill in
Municipal that addressed that in this
one area because towns were making it
difficult for students to get
housing go ahead represent Wallace if I
may the uh the study committee is the
transport vehicle if you will for this
reform I have a question um Repro for
representative Reed um representative
Reed when
you for the original bill was there any
discussion during um committee
commercial in the hearing I thought
maybe you were present for the hearing
um so I don't remember maybe other
members of the committee who were
present for the hearing I was but I I
did specifically ask the representative
for uh the senator who's the Prime
sponsor on the underlying Bill if uh at
the time she was testifying against
adding that non-gain Amendment and I
asked her would the senator be okay with
us adding the language rather than
replacing her underlying bill and I I
took it her answer to mean that that
would be
fine so followup please so this bill
that I'm asking you about wasn't that
the bill that was originally in um
Municipal and county in the house yes
and we have a member who serves on
Municipal who might be able to answer
more questions okay
and who is that represent go ahead thank
you
um the so this amendment is technically
not the exact same bill it's the same
subject matter but the wording is
changed
um uh there was not a list all of that
kind of stuff and and in that hearing we
did not discuss uh the commercial aspect
of um student housing it was mainly
about the
Discrimination um and whether or not you
know
people people next door or uh should be
able to control how many how many uh how
many nonrelated people are in a in a
building and then also regarding uh you
know is that a safety issue um and and
stuff like that we didn't go into into
uh
commercial aspect thank you may follow
up ahe so what my thinking is that um I
did some research and um I looked at the
um assesses database in uh for Duram at
least and I noticed that some of the
housing that's that's labeled student
housing is coded a Zone
commercial so let me follow up so my
thought is that when you have people
Behaving Badly um in different like
buildings baras or whatever
um the onus is on the commercial owner
to get that you know Behavior cleaned up
so that may be more um leverage for the
towns people who are offended by the
behavior of the students um so I mean
that's another way to think of that
thank you represent Reed I would just
add to that if that's is accurate that
um that kind of
brings into question some of the
complaints about ruining residential
neighborhoods if they're actually in
commercial zones to begin with then what
residential neighborhoods are you
ruining but I will say that we have to
kind of deal with what we have today and
I don't know about deadlines and stuff
but we're rapidly running out of time
this this amendment I I feel is
completely reasonable um and the study
committee on student housing will look
further into that issue that you just
raised excellent thank you okay are we
all set to vote okay is it
representative walls yes just I am
understand we we're all it's all late
but to address your question there are
many places in throughout the state
where there are existing Residential
Properties in zones that are now
commercial if those properties were
resid cease to be residential for a year
and a day they can no longer be occupied
as residential they would they would
they would Decay to a uh commercial oh
good information sry represent W go
ahead well there's also plenty of other
places that commercial does allow
residential components
uh it doesn't have to be changed uh
there's a lot of mobile home parks for
another one are allowed in commercial
zones so uh the testimony we heard is
that the student housing is basically
available for the majority of the town
around the college itself and that this
ordinance actually just starts to get
applied as you get towards the outskirts
neighborhoods uh thank you Mr chair
there are also mixed use zoned items as
well so can be commercial and
residential together so there are
there's that caveat as
well all right all those in favor of the
amendment please raise your
hand those
opposed okay so the motion car the
amendment carries 8 to two is there
another motion uh so we had to move out
to pass first before but I don't think
we did did we move out to pass first the
amendment was approved no but you have
to actually move out to pass then
approve an amendment and then this
motion is ought to pass is amended
automatically so I will move
retroactively ought to pass you already
did you already did that I moved the
amendment I moved the amendment which is
different than moving ought to pass
procedurally you have I'm sorry
procedurally you have to move ought to
pass have that seconded it was handled
then right it's already you did I did it
okay thank you so much Mr Mr clerk okay
in that case we need a second we need a
second
and I have no further discussion any
amended okay seeing none the clerk will
call roll uh Vice chairman barudi y
Representative makoni no representative
Walsh
no clerk votes yes representative yella
yes representative D Lorenzo yes
representative Reid yes representative
Murray yes representative Damon yes G
Alexander
yes 82 is there will there be a Minority
Report probably not okay I would move
consent if there's no objection is there
sure
it's yeah I'm going to leave I'm I'm
going to leave it on the regular
calendar so it doesn't end up at the end
of the schedule at the end of the
day okay so with that you're responsible
for two
reports yeah get them to me by like
tomorrow okay all right thank you we're